>> CHUNG: [SPEAKING IN FOREIGN LANGUAGE] Good
afternoon. Hi, everyone. I hope you guys having
a great time so far and still awake. It's
in the afternoon. My name is Fred Chung. I'm
a Developer Advocate at Google working on
Android, I'm actually working very closely
with Tim. You guys just learned many things
about group-bearing great looking applications.
And in this session, we're going to talk about
creating applications that are flexible enough
to be able to work across different hardware
configurations and implementations, and different
locales out there. So we're going to be discussing
some technical, you know, best practices and
techniques that, as developers, you can leverage
to build your apps such that they are flexible.
And I guess the expectation is that this is
an advanced topic. And I guess it would be
helpful if you have done one or maybe a few
Android apps and you just learned about making
your apps look good in the previous session
and now you want to make it, you know, even
better. And by the way, if you have any feedback
and have access to Wi-Fi, use the link displayed
up there to provide any feedback, we'd love
to hear it from you. Okay, let's get started.
I think you've seen this slide earlier, right?
The point here is that we've seen a lot of
momentum in the Android space in the--in the
previous few quarters and we are very excited
about it. We are seeing a lot of support from
various players in the ecosystem including,
obviously, the developers like you guys, users,
and the OEMs, right? As illustrated on the
slide here, starting on the upper left-hand
corner, you have the Motorola Milestone device.
You know, it's got a great physical keyboard,
big screen, and the right-hand side device,
you know, it's an X10 device; also a very
great-looking device. Down below, we have,
you know, the Galaxy Tab, seven-inch; a really,
really good looking device and I think you've--you
guys probably have seen that as well. And
on the right-hand side lower corner, you have
Google TV which was just launched a couple
of weeks ago--last week or a couple of weeks
ago. So the point here is that with these
different foreign factors, large screens,
small screens, physical keyboard, with trackball,
without trackball, the thing is with Android
,right, and the various implementations out
there, it appeals to people with different
hardware preferences, right? Some like physical
keyboards; some don't. And as developers,
it's very, very important for you to understand
that there are various techniques that are
available for you to create your application
to work across these multiple devices. And
the good thing is that despite these different
screen sizes and screen densities, what we've
found is that a lot of existing apps out there,
even, you know, those apps that were published
before, for example, the Galaxy Tab was available,
these apps looked fine on the Galaxy Tab.
They worked well on Galaxy Tab. Thanks to
the Android platform and we're going to look
at, you know, some specifics on how it works.
Okay? Let's have a look at how Android as
a system handles resource loading. So for
those of you that have built some apps, you
probably are familiar with this directory
structure in Eclipse. This is actually a screenshot
from Eclipse. And it's got a bunch of directory;
one of those is RES, R-E-S, which stands for
resources. It includes things such as drawables.
What we call drawable refers to the bitmaps,
the pictures that you like to put on your
application, layouts. You know, these layout
XML files define the, you know, how your application
is presented to users, and Android does a
pretty good job in separating out the presentation
logic from the business logic which makes
it very, very easy. It's for you to reiterate
the layout if you wanted without affecting
the business logic. And if you've noticed
on the screenshot, specifically drawable,
you see a couple of funny identifiers next
to it; drawable-hdpi, drawable-mdpi. So what
do these identifiers mean? Well, through these
qualifiers, these allow you to provide alternative
resources for different configurations. What
that means is that for different pictures
that you put in these different photos that
have the pre--the different suffixes, hdpi,
mdpi, what happens is that at runtime, the
system will determine, "Hey, what's my current
configuration?" And then it automatically
picks up--picks the pictures that you have
prepared from these respective directories
and present to users. There's actually a bunch
of, you know, qualifiers out there. There's
about a dozen of them, 12 of them. And most
notably, I like to share with you four that
are related to today's topic, namely, the
screen size, the screen density, right, because
these define sort of the different foreign
factors that are available out there; and
screen orientation, right? You can--you know,
always certain that your users would rotate
their device while using your application;
and SDK versions. And we're going to talk
more about that today. You may ask, "Well,
there are a lot of devices out there," right,
"with different screen sizes and density.
How does the system actually match these different
screen sizes?" Right? Therefore, example,
3.8-inch, 4-inch screen, right, how does the
system go about matching these different physical
screen sizes with the identifiers that you've
defined? I think it's best described using
a diagram like this. It's a three by three
matrix as you can see. Across the top, it
defines the various buckets or categories
of densities. So we are talking about low-density,
medium-density, and high-density. And the
vertical access, you have the different screen
sizes; small, medium, large, right? Just like
when you go to Starbucks, for example. When
you order coffee, you order different sizes
instead of the exact volume. How Android works
is that, you know, it sort of maps the different
implementations out there to one of these
buckets. For example, the G1 in the middle,
it is actually our baseline model. It is considered
a normal screen and medium-density device.
To the right of the G1, you have the Droid
X, the Nexus Ones; these are considered enormous
screen device and high-density devices. So
through this mechanism, Android knows how
to map these different device implementations
out there to one of the--one of the nine predefined
buckets, right here. And as I said earlier,
if you look at the directory structure screenshot
here, it--at run time, the system would map
the different layout in this case to a different
actual hardware. So that's screen size. Screen
density works very similarly. If you look
at the directory structure up there, drawable-hidpi,
drawable-lowdpi so you just create different
graphics, right? For example, if you have
a graphical icon that represents your company,
you want to, you know, put the icons into
these different directories.
So in terms of presenting drawables or these
graphical elements on screen, I guess one
of the goals of the system is to make sure
these different graphics appear at approximately
the same size across devices of different
densities as illustrated on the three diagrams
here. So you have a low sort of a three grids,
right? The one--the one on your left represents
a low DPI screen and the one to your right
represents a higher density screen. And the
system is trying to make sure, for example,
if you want to put a logo like the star. Let's
say, the star represents your company's logo.
You want to--you want these stars to show
up at approximately the same size across different
devices. And if you look at the number of
pixels involved in one of these stars or your
company's logo, on the left hand side, right,
the number of pixels involved is fewer than
those on the right hand side, right, in order
to retain the shape of the picture. And at
run time, the system is going to either scale
the pictures up or down based on the availability
of these graphics and the actual device that's
being run on. And when it comes to the generation
of these graphics, for example, when you're
using your favorite photo editing software,
Photoshop, or a GIMP, or whatever, I guess
the technique is that you always want to first
of all, identify the buckets, the different
density buckets that you like to support,
right? For example, you want to, say, support
all three, you always want to create the graphics
with the highest density first, right, and
then scale them down based on these principles.
For example, if the width of the highest density
graphic is 150, and then you want to scale
it down by creating a smaller graphics with,
you know, 100 pixel in width because that's
the difference that's represented by the three-grid
model. Well, so that's concept. Let's have
a look at actual implementation. I drew this
picture. Is it pretty? I'm proud of it. So
this is the actual screen shot that I took
from a G1 device. As you can recall, G1 device
is classified as a medium screen size and
medium density. So it looks okay, right? What
if I just use the same graphic and then render
it on a medium screen device and higher density
device like the Nexus One? You'll get something
on the right. While it still works, the system,
you know, does its magic to scale it up to
a screen of higher density, you can see that
the graphics on the right is blurred, right?
Can you guys notice that difference? And then
what if you want to optimize it, right? We
always want to make sure our applications
look good as we learned from the previous
session, right? So you want to take the approach
that I just described by introducing a higher
density graphics in the HDPI photo of drawable.
And this is the result. And I don't know if
you can tell from the projection but I can,
you know, noticeably see the difference in
crispiness of the picture in the middle and
that's generated from--on the same device
on the Nexus One, but with the optimized assets.
So we just learned that the system does actually
a pretty good job in auto scaling in the different
images for you, right? What if you're getting
adventurous, right? What if you have actually
identified ways that you think warrants the
needs for you to do the scaling itself, right?
My advice is for you is don't do it. Let the
system do its job. The system knows to do
it pretty well. And if you, for example, insist--if
you insist on doing it, I would like to ask
you to re-think. Ask your colleagues, your--the
neighbors next to you, ask your boyfriends,
girlfriends for their confirmation. Is this
the right thing for you to do? The point being,
the system is smart enough and it knows how
to do it for you pretty well. But let's say
you want to do it, right? Here's the step
involved. There are a couple of parameters
involved if you look at the code snippets
when you want to render in Bitmap; bitmapfactory.options,
right? It's–-it comes with a default options
and you want to overwrite it. And the specific
two parameters that you want to overwrite
are the InDensity and the InTargetDensity.
What these parameters mean is that the InDensity
is actually the density for the incoming drawable
that you want to render. And the InTargetDensity
is the density of the actual device that the
program is running on. So at run time, normally,
the system is going to scale your pixels based
on this formula; InTargetDensity divided by
InDensity. And if you want to disable that
auto-scaling effect, right? You want to, you
know, make sure that formula equates to one.
And the way to do it is to make sure those
values match by, you know, manually setting
the values to be identical for the three values
you see on the last bullet, okay? But again,
I request you to re-think if you are kind
of wondering about whether it makes sense
for you to manually manipulate the pictures.
Okay, we talked about screen sizes and densities.
What about orientation as I alluded to you
earlier in the session? So as I mentioned
earlier that users will probably rotate the
devices, right, you have the option of just
letting the operating system handle the rotation
for you or you can disable it and decide to
handle the rotation yourself. And keep in
mind that there are different hardware implementations
out there, right? They are, you know, naturally
landscape devices, they are naturally portrait
devices, and there are some square devices.
I guess the key point here is that when you
are developing an application, don't always
assume that, okay, it's going be always be
run on a milestone, for example, where users,
you know, have the tendency of holding it
upright or in a portrait mode. Be flexible
to expect the possibility that they might
have a natural tendency to use it in a landscape
mode. For tablet, for example, right? Why
the device seven-inch Samsung tablet, for
example. I think the natural orientation is
probably landscape. [INDISTINCT] a lot of
people would like to use it to read e-books
or whatever, and therefore I guess the natural
orientation could be landscape. And if you
want to determine the natural orientation
at run time, you can use code--this code snippet,
right? You can get it--hand it to the display
object and read the orientation based on the
get orientation API and that particularly
API's been duplicated. And if you are running
on Froyo or if you're targeting on Froyo,
you want to use to get rotation API, okay?
Let's talk a little bit about, you know, best
practices involved with creating flexible
UIs. So there are two screen shots up there
while the two applications are perfectly functional,
they look a little bit odd. The one on the
right looks a little bit odd, and the reason
being those were generated using an Absolute
Layout. And for those of you that may not
be familiar with Absolute Layout is that it's
a method to layout graphical elements on the
UI. For example, you want to specify that,
"I want to place the input box five pixels
below the top and 20 pixels to the right of
the left--of the left edge." And while this
works on the screen shot on the left hand
side which was produced from G1 which is a
low density device and a screen shot on the
right hand side is come--actually came from
Nexus One which is a higher density device.
As we learned from the star diagrams, the
three stars diagrams, the number of pixels
involved--while the number of pixels involved
to define the input box might be identical,
it's narrower on higher density devices, right?
So you can't reliably depend on Absolute Layout
and we advise you to kind of use another method
which is Relative Layout. It is basically
a method to specify UI elements based on relative
positioning with respect to other elements.
So let's use this example. You would say,
"I want to put the input box to the right
of the label,” which is called input, just
like that, and then the system would automatically
put it to the right of it. And then, you want
to use something called DIP, density-independent
pixel, rather than absolute pixel because,
again, you don't want--you want to avoid absolute
pixels for the various reasons that I just
mentioned before and use this density-independent
pixel. What happens is that remember the three-by-three
matrix, right? So that's--that defines the
logical pixel unit. And then once defined,
the system would automatically scale that
based on the actual hardware implementation
that the app is deployed on. And as far as
defining text size, you want to use something
called SP instead of, again, absolute pixel
to define the size of the text because what
we've seen is that while the text size may
look okay on one implementation, namely, for
example, G1, it may look like a small font
on a Milestone, for example, just because,
again, the differences in different screen
densities. Okay, here's another observation
that I've learned over the months. This is
an actual screenshot that was taken from a
Galaxy Tab which is defined as a high, you
know, large screen-sized and high density.
And what happens is that if you have a Legacy
app, right? A Legacy app probably has the
targetSdkVersion defined as something smaller
than four like a cupcake, a three or something.
And then, you know, if you can recall back
in Version 3, the difference screen sizes
were not introduced to the SDK. So the system
would think, "Okay, this app is not capable
of being rendered on a larger screen, so I'm
going to put a border around it." This is
something what we call a Shoebox. And, again,
while it works functionally, it doesn't look
good, right? It's not appealing to your users
and that's not to the best of your interest.
And one quick way to sort of a remedy this
situation is to make sure that in your Android
Manifest, you have the support screens element
properly declaring the support of large screens,
or medium screens, or any density to true.
That way, the system knows that, "Okay, this
application is probably able to be rendered
on a bigger screen and it would stretch it
to take the four sides of the screen." All
right. So we talked about the screen size
and screen densities, the different form factors
that you need to be aware of. What about the
different versions out there, right, because
as you probably can recall, we have brought
out a few versions out there over the years.
And as illustrated in this picture here, right,
this is a panoramic picture I took with my
G1 several days ago and as you can see, we
have the various sculptures out there on the
lawn. This is coming from the Mountain View
Headquarters. And traditionally, whenever
the team launches a new version, they put
up a new sculpture. So as you can see the
cupcakes, the donuts, and whatever, over the
years. So the expectation is that, you know,
there would always be multiple versions out
there in the market and we're going to talk
a little about how to--how do you go about
handling that in the future. And also one
more thing, last Friday, they put out--put
out a new sculpture out there and that's what--not
what I'm going to talk about today. I don't
have more information there. Okay, so we talked
with a lot of developers, right? A very--a
question that comes up over and over again
is that, "Okay, you have multiple versions
out there, which version should I target?"
Right? This is our smart answer to it; “It
really depends.” And then there's a number
of reasons, right, there's a number of factors
involved. And the two most important factors,
I think, are the number of users and the number
of recent features or the number of advanced
features you want to implement. In this non-scientific
graph that I drew--hand drawn, you can probably
see that, you know, the more advanced of a
feature that you wanted to target, the fewer
the number of users that it probably can benefit.
And the reason being, you know, it take--it
generally takes some time for users out there
on the field to upgrade to newer versions
for whatever reasons. And the question really
is, you're going to ask yourself, "Okay, for
the app that you are trying to develop, what's
my feature sets?" Right? You want to look
at feature sets and then try to compare the
various features that are available on the
various version of Android. For example, if
you want to, you know, have a news widget
kind of thing, that was introduced way back
in 1.5, which means that, you know, the SDK
version that you can use to target is probably--you
can--you can go back all the way to 1.5 which
will appear to almost, you know, practically
100% of the devices out there versus if you
want to target, you know, the data backup
feature or live wallpaper features that are
introduced in more recent versions. You're
going to have to just, you know, balance that
yourself to figure out, "Okay, what's my cost
benefit? Additional features or relatively
speaking, fewer users?" But over time, you
can sort of expect that users will be upgraded
to newer versions and newer devices that come
out will be running newer versions. So here's
another tool that helps us make that decision
like, which version should I target. And by
the way, this is publicly available on our
websites and it basically illustrates that
over time, you know, it confirms the point
that I just I make; over time, more and more
devices will have newer versions. And if you
look at this graph, anything with Éclair
or 2.1, or more recent, we're talking about
roughly 75% of devices out there, which is
pretty great. Okay, so with the different
versions out there, right, I mentioned that
you can expect to see multiple versions out
there; out two to three versions or whatever.
How do you go about creating an application
that would work seamlessly across these different
versions? So, here's the thing that you want
to figure out, right, with API changes. For
example, you're developing on 2.2, right,
Froyo. You might be leveraging or using some
APIs that might not be available on older
versions. How do you make sure the backward
compatibility of your application to maximize
your reach? I guess the general recommendation
is leverage Java Reflection, right? At runtime,
you want figure out, okay, on my--on the current
system that I'm running is the particular
class or is the particular method that I'm
trying to use is available? And then you can
provide a wrapper around that reflection logic,
right? Whenever you want to access that information
from your business logic, you want to poke
the--poke the class and say, "Hey, is this
class or is this method available at runtime?"
And if it is, use it. If not, you're going
to have to have a backup plan. So here's the
general strategy in theory and let's have
a look at some actual code. In this use case,
I'm trying to use the getDensity method from
the canvas class, as you can see pointed to
you by the arrow, right? And this getDensity
method specifically was introduced back in
level four or at Donut. What if I want to
target Cupcake devices that don't have this
method available? So I would create this wrapper
class called Canary with a static--method
is just a Java Reflection class that represents
the method itself. And then you try to say,
get me the method called getDensity. And if
that getDensity method is found on the runtime,
it will return the reference to that method
and that reference, based on this code snippet,
it start in "mGetDensity" reference handle.
If it's not found, an exception will be thrown
and, you know, you're going to have to do
something differently. So that's the wrapper
method. And let's have a look at how this
method should be used. We're talking about
the same class--the same wrapper class. And
whenever you need to access the getDensity,
you want to do something like this, you want
to check for the reference, right? If the
method was successfully identified, it's going
to be available in the mGetDensity reference
or handle. If it's found, then invoke it.
If it's not found in the [INDISTINCT] class,
you might want to do something different by
having--in this particular instance, having
a default variable or something so that your
application won't crash, which is a great
thing for users--from a user experience standpoint.
So that was a new method, right? What about
you using a class that might not be familiar--I
mean, that might not be available in the previous
version of Android? Very, very similar approach
is used here. Again, create a wrapper class,
right? In the wrapper class within a static
block, you want to try to load that class,
in this case, called EventLog, which was introduced
in Froyo. It's something used to read diagnostic
information at the system level. You want
to try to load this using the forName method,
okay? If it's found, everything is good. If
it's not found, an exception will be thrown.
And then there's this checkAvailable--whoops.
There's this checkAvailable method, which
is a static method, MT method, and the idea
is that a caller can call this checkAvailable.
And since this is static, it would--it would
invoke the execution of the static block above
it to check the forName and so on and so forth.
Okay? And the third method in this wrapper
is the writeEvent, which is nothing but a
wrapper for the actual class that you are
trying to invoke. And then here's the actual
usage of the wrapper class. For example, in
this MyActivity, you want to use it, so you
would do EventLogWrapper.checkAvailable. As
you can recall, this is the static method
that is used to trigger the invocation of
the static block which calls forName, right?
If forName works well, everything is good,
right? And then you want set the boolean to
true. The boolean is about called mAPIAvailable,
set into true, indicating that, yes, the class
is available, otherwise, if the exception
is affirmed which implies that the class is
not available, then you would set that boolean
to false. So when you are actually trying
to use this class, you would just check for
the, you know, the boolean value. If it's
true, then it means that the class is available,
then use it. If not, do something differently.
So this is one of the ways developers can
use to make sure they have maximum compatibility
across different versions. But I would say
it--while this is a good method, it may not
work for all features. For example, account
manager which is more involved than just making
API cause, that's something that, you know,
that makes it very, very hard to use a strategy
like this to maximize the compatibility. But
for the most part, you can leverage what I--what
we just described to kind of make sure your
application is version-proof, sort of. Okay,
we talked about, you know, version compatibility.
Let's move on to localization, right? We are
talking about an international audience here.
You have pretty much have access to sell your
application for Android market to the rest
of the other countries that support Android
market. So let's have a quick look at localization
here. Here's a quick code snippet to show,
you know, a button, you want to render a button
on the screen, and put a text on it. Voila,
right? It works perfectly fine. But can this
be improved? We all, as programmers, are lazy,
right? We have the tendency to just hot code
labels. And while it works, again, you know,
it may not be that flexible in the event that
you want to localize your application to,
say, English speaking countries or Spanish
speaking audience. So to do that, it's really
simple. For those experienced programmers
out there, you guys should be all familiar
with the resource bundles concept, same ideas
applicable here. In the values folder of your
project, you just have to create different
values folders prefix or suffix rather by
different languages and regions; for example
-ES, -PT region Brazil, for example. Within
the strings.XML files that--which we'll see
later, it shows you that how you can put different
languages into the different bundles. So this
is the setup. So how does it work at runtime?
At runtime, the system would sort of go through
this logic, the four bullet points out there;
what is my current system locale, right? It
could be Portuguese or something else, right,
English or whatever. And the thing is it's
got a default version--default locale. And
at runtime, the--it would query the app package,
the APK file to say, hey, if this developer
has paid attention in Fret's talk and created
the different folders with the different localized
strings, and if they did and if it's able
to find the corresponding folder that matches
their current locale, then it would use it.
If it's not found, it falls back to the default,
the values one without any suffixes. Okay,
here's an actual example of formatting string.
You want to put a label and a text, right?
This is an application that tries to figure
out the number of engineers needed to change
a light bulb. And in the different strings,
you know, different localized strings, resource
files that I mentioned, you just put in the
contents, the localized contents. The first
version, you know, it's Portuguese. I hope
that's right. That's based on Google Translate
output. And the second strings.XML contains
the strings, you know, in other language,
in English, in this case. Going back to the
code snippets, this is how you would instantiate
this string by calling, you know, getResources.getString
by referring to the R.string.question, which
automatically maps to one of these depending
on, again, the current system locale. And
as you can see, you can also merge data at
runtime. You can, you know, merge an integer
value to the string that--to be displayed
on the UI. Okay, we’ve talked about localization.
How about from an Android market standpoint,
right? Once you've developed your app, you've
tested your app, you want to distribute it.
Android Market plays a very important role.
It's sort of a matchmaking role between, you
know, apps and devices. On one hand, you have
a bunch of developers creating great apps,
publishing apps. And on the other hand, you
have a bunch of devices checking in, "Hey,
get me some apps. Get me some apps." And whenever
these devices check in, they report their
device hardware capabilities. And different
hardware versions or different hardware models,
as we've talked about, have different capabilities;
some have cameras, some don't, so on and so
forth. And let’s see, you know, what sort
of mechanism Android Market has to make sure
actually the intended audience gets access
to application. The worst thing that could
happen is that if your application requires
camera and what if the device doesn't have
a camera? That would be a bad user experience.
So there are two sides. On the application
publishing side through Android Manifest,
you can create, you know, roughly six different
filters, right? And I'm just calling out four
ones that are relevant to this talk; uses
features, uses configurations. And these tags
actually tells the system, hey, my app actually
will require telephony features, or it does
require OpenGL. Or in a case of users configuration,
it says, okay, my app requires a physical
keyboard for whatever reason, or it uses SDK.
My app requires a minimum version of SDK be
it Froyo or Cupcake or whatever. And then
you can also define things such as the support
screen; what kind of screen sizes can my app
support? So through these different cues,
Android Market knows, okay, here are the apps'
capabilities or requirements. And then these
are created through Android Manifest. But
through other methods, you can also specify,
okay, here's the geographical location I want
to target. Here's the carrier restrictions
for making my apps available and native platform
if your application uses NDK which we saw
in Tim's talk. It--you know, NDKs targets
a specific hardware and then this is kind
of--these are kind of filtering criteria you
can specify. And you can have a look at this
URL to understand the full definition of these
different criteria. And also--so we talked
about app publishing aspect of it. A U.S.
developer can say, "Okay, here are the requirements
for my app." But for those devices that are
checking in, how do we make sure those devices
conform to a certain standard? And that's
done through Android compatibility definition,
right? If you go to the URL, you can find
that, you know, this definition defines things
such as the minimum requirements an Android
compatible device must have. For example,
touch screens, USB slots, so on and so forth,
it defines, you know, some of the minimum
requirements to be compatible with Android,
and to ensure that these devices that are
checking in to Android Market actually conform
to a certain standard so apps won't break.
And from an OEM standpoint, they would have
to make sure that they run through the CTS,
compatibility test suites, to make sure they
are compatible. Okay. So that's kind of completes
the whole cycle from app publishing to devices
checking in, how Android markets make sure
your apps are only visible to the intended
audience. Okay. I guess that wraps up my talk.
And to summarize, I want to say that it's
actually pretty straightforward to make sure
your app could be, you know, compatible to
various devices out there with different hardware
configurations and versions. And I strongly
encourage you to have a look at our online
documentation for the information that we
just discussed. Thank you very much. [SPEAKING
IN FOREIGN LANGUAGE].